é quando os meninos os olhos
pra falar nessa tese de dex unifesp eu
pensei bastante
vocês porque na minha longa vida afinal
de contas eu sou mais é do que o pai do
cid
ah eu tenho uma série de experiências né
a na medicina que me fascinaram
completamente eu poderia contar pra
vocês por exemplo há a história de um
pai para que nós acabamos de publicar
onde nós descobrimos que o efeito
fundador de um gene estava na grécia e
nós acompanhamos a migração desses
indivíduos da grécia para espanha da
espanha chegando no brasil
mas quem descobriu a mutação fomos nós
uma experiência fascinante uma expedição
científica extraordinária poderia
comentar com vocês também duas doenças
que o acompanha desde que eu era um
jovem residente que o hipotiroidismo
congênito quando é gravíssima e que a
nós acabamos de descobrir uma das causas
moleculares dela o mais fascinante mente
ainda da paralisia periódica tirotóxica
que também eu levei 30 anos entre a
descrição do primeiro caso do brasil até
um pós graduando meu o magnus que
descobriu a causa molecular são
histórias fascinantes mas aí eu me
lembrei do meu amigo que era professor
da fundação getúlio vargas e hoje
professor no texas e que foi o meu
introdutor esta questão da cultura das
organizações que o professor miguel
caldas que no dia discutindo sobre como
a formar as pessoas
o miguel assim e eu estava falando que a
questão familiar é importante para lá e
ele falou assim você é um bom marido
puxou essa pergunta do nada eu falei eu
acho eu e outros 43 anos e um homem
casado eu falei são um ótimo marido
falou errado
temos que montar a sua mulher ela que
tem que dizer se você bom marido não né
então tô fazendo essa nova produção e
perder dois minutos deu certo né o que
contraria uma conferência ted mas eu
adoro ser um cara do contrato certo né
até pra quebrar paradigmas né
adoro quebrar paradigmas mas eu vou
cumprir o tempo a e eu falei o que eu
vou falar na ted conference
mas eu fiquei com medo de chegar aqui
tudo metido né afinal de contas não só
da faculdade de medicina da usp
eu sou do paulistinha da escola né
a falar como se um bom orientador dá
certo porque de fato não só eu acho como
eu tenho uma série de documentações tá
certo acabei de fazer eu tenho mais de
50 pessoas que orientei né
mas aí fui perguntar aos meus colegas
acham que é é muita nitidez da minha
parte só não é isso que você faz muito
bem por favor fale vocês como eu tenho
usado esse é essa parte com a justificar
por que eu ainda acho da humanidade com
todos os 52 mil anos o que é um pouco
pretensioso chegar aqui e falar como é
um modelo certo
e outra coisa esse modelo tem muita
gente que não concorda será que eu sou
bonzinho negão gosto de caminhar minha
esposa do antes de um monte de durão aí
no sistema né
eu vou dividir essa fala em duas partes
na primeira o que eu acho que são um dos
elementos para que você se torne na
verdade orientador o mentor nós somos a
vida inteira tá certo
o próprio michael e falo aqui que ele
foi um pouco menos do lado do outro
irmão dele né
e essa frase que vocês estão vendo pra
mim é um dos maiores fãs da minha vida
tá certo né não da minha vida mas que eu
aprendi lendo as memórias do pedro nava
e que na minha pessoa é uma verdade
absoluta certo eu vou repetir com você
eu aprendi muito com os meus professores
as coisas são muito grato
eu aprendi mais com os meus colegas do
que com os meus professores mas eu
aprendi e continuo aprendendo todos os
dias muito mais com os meus alunos do
que com todos os demais a sério esse
mesmo tempo da grécia acaba de aprender
por causa de um aluno nosso da escola tá
certo
lucas é a que realmente me desvendou
toda essa história de como você pode
buscar um ancestral por cálculos
matemáticos a a outra coisa que eu
considero não sei se aqui o é muito
relevante para você querer ser o
orientador é gostar genuinamente de
pessoas e de ensinar
se você não gosta de pessoas e pode ser
um ótimo profissional está certo mas
nunca você pode ser um bom orientador
então é essencial porque muitas vezes a
pessoa não gosta de seu orientador que
tem que mergulhar na vida do cara
você tem que entender os problemas dele
você tem que ouvir ouvir para que
realmente exista uma empatia
extraordinária entre esses dois
elementos e com isso você consiga o
melhor das coisas não há outra coisa e
vocês possam a pode achar até graça é
que a agente deve buscar pessoas que têm
feedback né
eu tive e continuo tendo né fernando
alberto por exemplo um que acabou de
falar que ele continua sendo o meu cara
do bullying informal sem entender o que
dizer ele a pessoa que toda vez que eu
tô fraquejando o fernando vem com uma
daquelas certinha mas um bully mesmo né
porque eu falo é óbvio que eu prefiro um
feedback gentil carinhoso ano no momento
apropriado e tal mas não despreza uma
pessoa que fala num momento inadequado
tá certo o que faz o que a gente chama
hoje de bullying que realmente não há
pois muitas vezes algumas verdades que
você não consegue enxergar auto engano
meu maior defeito dos humanos está certo
mas não consegue chegar aí vem aquele
meu amigo de um manda setinha eu
acredito muito bullying que eu recebi tá
aqui nessa escola tem gente que faz
bonita boa outra coisa na sua formação
você procura tem o maior número possível
de mentores de qualidade está certo
ah eu tive é grandes discussões
doutrinárias alguns professores da
escola tem a mania do guru certo né
gente começa no segundo ano fica atrás
do cara lá é péssimo isso aí porque você
pode ter as qualidades desse indivíduo
mas você vai carregar também toda aquela
visão dele né
então quem é o maior número de eleitores
possíveis por isso eu sou um entusiasta
da residência médica
curiosa que foi um dos maiores médicos e
surgiu a além de bom médico ele inventou
a residência médica na residência médica
o boom da residência por duas coisas
o primeiro que você não roda só com
aquele famoso professor senhora com
vários professores está certo e com isso
você vai ver que olha tem muita gente
boa e não apenas um
a segunda coisa você não quer aprender
tudo com o professor alex alguma coisa
melhor senão aprender com o professor
você não aprende com r 2 434 eles são
melhores naquela cozinha do que o velho
professor deu certo né então a isso
transfira para a nossa vida tem o maior
número de
inventores amplo possível está certo
outra coisa eu não sei se eu sou um
otimista por natureza né
mais eu já tive orientador carrasco
orientador uma chef certo né
carrasco ou f da pesquisa nem falar
exatamente o que eu chamo de um carrasco
f da p é aquele cara que só te dá dura
tá certo só que exigem não dá nada em
troca
eu acho que aprendi com eles é a
primeira vez um pouco mais esperto
segunda não ser como eles certo né
i sabe que aconteceu com eles não deram
em nada deu certo tiveram um momento de
glória e sumiram na poeira da história
tá certo
se você for um cara carrasco a longo
prazo você não vai durar porque as
pessoas não gostam certo
a outra coisa não se espera que os
fracassos está uma história ótima dica
porque eu queria ter sido cirurgião e eu
falei que se ele não quer ser o joão eu
tentava nos pontos e não fez não é só
treinar treinar então né
eu entrei não é uma cirurgia né foi uma
fracasso da minha vida tá certa porque
eu percebi que eu gostava das coisas
clínicas e que não tinha jeito nem
temperamento temperamento aguentar
aquelas gritaria de r2 r3 e r4 acima de
mim é quando tinha razão ou eu não tinha
a mesma habilidade cirúrgica que tinha
meus colegas a um dia eu estava de
plantão o plantão eu r1 do ps 7 19% você
sair às 22 até passagem do plantão e no
dia seguinte dizendo às 7 horas da manhã
aí quando ela seis e meia entre um
baleado aí o chefe de plantão chamou eu
dou total de mortes que era meu colega
vamos lá no baleado entrou no baleada
seis e meia seis e 40 sem almoçar e saiu
da cirurgia às três da manhã
a gente saiu da cirurgia 24 anos uma
fome brutal tá certo né
e tenho que trabalhar no dia seguinte 7
nós fomos gestão do hospital que já era
ruim só tinha umas laranjas assim
aquelas laranjas é que depois eu sabia
que o tio do menino do interior ter
sabido que a laranja bem né
ortiz cor laranja ficou perfeita que ela
planeja
nenhuma dentada no branco a minha na
primeira roda já que for e cheio de
dentadas certo né
quando li as duas laranjas também impõe
eu falei ortiz
eu não dou pra essa m se entendeu eu vou
sair desse diálogo dessa vez em cirurgia
e aí virei clínico mas então eu só vou
dizer que fracasso é importante eu acho
que eu me tornei um cara importante pra
escola paulista
mas vocês precisarem até agora isso você
tem que aprender inglês
se não aprender inglês estão altas
business está certo se quiserem ser se
quiserem ser o investigador minimamente
com credibilidade e deu certo
só em itu bom agora pra ser orientador
a primeira coisa desculpe você tem que
ser muito bom naquilo que vocês fazem
certo meu querido amigo ídolo e eduardo
andrade
ele é referência mundial no que ele faz
caras e sabe oque vocês a premissa sou
né
você tem que ser uma referência nacional
e internacional em que obteu saber falar
tá certo né busca excelência vá para o
exterior
eu particulamente eu falei que sou
bonzinho mas eu faço o possível quando
não impossível para mandar todas as
provas dos pós-graduandos posterior
porque o que eu chamo do processo disse
provincianismo ação ou como eu chamava
antigamente eu tenho raízes caipiras de
desde a acusação nós brasileiros somos
jacko caipira fora do mundo civilizado
de produção de ciência das outras
enormes boas qualidades é certo mas do
ponto de vista científico ajude um pouco
atrasado e você tem que ir pra fora tá
certo né eu quando fui um ainda mais eu
fui há 40 anos atrás uma vez há 30 anos
atrás da outra vez está certo aquilo
mudou a minha vida e é isso que eu
procuro a convencer os meus alunos está
certo
outra coisa que também que muita gente
me critica a atitude ea atitude 2 está
certo atitude 1
no começo eu protejo o cara mesmo ou ela
desculpas resulta de um problema de
gênero aqui é também muito mais alunas
mulheres do que homens
eu protejo mesmo porque porque ele é
jovem faz besteira eu tenho aquela
técnica então 30 anos trabalha comigo
fica com aquela cara assim sempre olha
ele vai contaminar mas não sei o quê
então eu protejo mesmo e elas falam lá
vem o pai santa
agora à medida que eu vejo que o cara
vai dando frutos né
eu vou expondo e no final o patrocínio
mesmo deus era o meu maior orgulho é vai
ter uma vaga eu preparo cara eu fiquei
não influenciou na banca angolana mas eu
eu estimulo certo que eu acho que a
função eu me sinto como é minha
obrigação patrocinar o cara que eu
formei e atitude segundo é uma atitude
mais psicológico e muita gente tem medo
é um negócio você aceitar e comprar
mesmo aqueles aquele aluno com o maior
carinho com o negócio você escutar a
escutar é absolutamente ascensão
outro aspecto é isso é e eu aprendi diz
o velho o velho não os 40 anos é
explorar as minhas fortalezas e deixar
um mínimo aquelas coisas que eu sou ruim
torcer por exemplo estatística eu
reconheço que não sou bom estatístico
não era bom de matemática no mundo
estatística
mas esses 40 anos que eu oriento sempre
arrumei um santo lá que se gostava de
estatísticas
assim sendo não durou toda a vida mas o
que eu tinha uns quatro santos é certo
que estão carregando toda parte da
estatística nossa com muita propriedade
a ouvir
tem que ouvir e eu eu eu acho que esse
negócio de 200 do norte só trouxe um
slide aqui pra vocês verem
eu falei do óleo agora quer falar do
floral brait que foi morta disse rosa
salientou a clínica médica foi o bate
inventou ainda tecnologia e ofurô bike
1.144 ou seja 73 anos quando foi
presidente da sociedade americana de
investigação clínica
ele escreveu um pequeno gerenciais de
novo ninguém investigue acham que vale
até hoje tá certo que hoje não seria
aceita porque a primeira coisa que ele
fala assim
hoje há há há
ambon otago do intelecto certo hoje
seria visto com uma coisa tão
politicamente correto é certo mas onde
ele descreve aquelas coisas que você tem
que fazer aquelas coisas que você não
tem que fazer especialmente naquelas que
se você não tem que fazer esse é um lobo
solitário e sempre você tem grupo está
certo né
e você virar o executivo aí acabou a sua
carreira a científica certo né
outra coisa tem que ser feito face às
vezes é chato eu reconheço mas vale a
pena porque a é muito importante você
conversar e conhecer muito o seu pós
graduando certo
ah e se eu voltar àquele slide anterior
mas eu só vou mostrar esses aqui que eu
acho muito interessante e depois eu
posso vascaína na apresentação que eu
trabalhei na sua peça não é como no
grupo a lida da saúde durante 1 67 anos
e junto com o doutor mário saad junto
com o professor zago hoje a reitor da
usp a nós desenvolvemos essa questão é
um dos dez mandamentos que na verdade
são 11 tudo certo né de um bom projeto
de pesquisa mas são aspectos muito
interessantes
aí pra vocês que estão se iniciando né
então é você tem que escolher uma área
de interesse que esse é um interesse não
é uma coisa muito técnica senão ninguém
se interessa né
mas de preferência ainda menos ocupada
né
sem antecipar os resultados e realizar o
primeiro estudo deu certo
assista conferências e artigos fora da
sua área de interesse isso é muito
importante você ter os insights encontre
um balanço e um projeto de baixo e alto
risco mas inclua sempre a sua rotina
projeto de alto risco eu deixo esse lado
aqui só pra mostrar pra vocês nesse
último mês
eu tive três pedidos aceitos que foi
exatamente um de baixo que é baixo e
está no enorme corte que nós temos em
carteira uma diferença de ódio
o que acontece com o pet/ct tse não tem
nenhuma experiência brasileira grande
mas isso não tem nenhum pacto
internacional que publicamos na revista
a mas é importante mostrar uma
experiência foi muito boa
aí tem um médio que era uma outra enorme
coragem dedicação medular da tiróide tt
aproveitando um convênio que a gente
tinha com o hospital aiims tem
a afa foi muito importante uma revista
internacional mas tem um projeto de
altíssimo risco tá certo que nós
entramos descobriu uma causa molecular
de pugilismo conjunto que é uma coisa do
peru entender porque é no
desenvolvimento da tireóide é uma coisa
que fazem hormônio em tantas coisas que
fazem tireóide migrar e realmente num
ano jim que faz o hormônio ele atrapalha
a migração da série uma coisa nova
acabou de ser aceito é uma coisa
espetacular alto risco a gente tinha
recursos para isso
eu roubava um pouco de dinheiro do mago
da janeth central mas a gente investiu
nesse projeto certo né
e deu certo ah bom e último a 2 o
necessário tempo para pensar se você
quer ser um pesquisador tem que ter
tempo para pensar se não você não vai
adiante e tem que trabalhar certo aqui
no meu tempo de ferro está certo que a
gente roubava muitas entre fica hoje
você roda - entre fica né
então isso é muito bom porque quanto
mais excêntrica roda mais sorte você tem
aí deixando a no minuto final
eu acho que tem algumas coisas é muito
importante está de concelho apenas a
quem pede tanto que também porque você
vê o orientador e fica tentado a ficar
dando conselho palpite na vida de todo
mundo não faça isso porque o cavalo você
orientadora do seu aluno em uma equipe
grande e faça relacionamento com colegas
com eventuais concorrentes com outras
universidades está certo né
jerry bem-estar laboratório minha
secretária é obrigado a função principal
a principal dela na secretária geral bem
estar a servir cafezinho com um tá
triste vai lá e pergunta o que é de 30
cm já bem estar tem que falar inglês e
outra coisa
orientadora para toda a vida tá é a
última piada que eu vou contar
há muitos anos atrás a gente tava no mit
nos estados unidos estava com a gripe
daquelas né
e aí uma tinha algumas orientações
momento outras vezes orientando o edital
fica muito próximo com a minha gripe e
foram lá me levaram um coquetel de
remédios haiti um cara marido recente de
uma aluna de outro professor
nossa como você tem preocupação com esse
professor aí ela falou olha fiquei
sabendo seguintes o orientador para a
vida toda
casamento não sei não acho que o seu
também passou um mês
a menina visa eu me separei do cara
porque muito obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]